speaking of Ron DeSantis this is a sort
of like if the shoe fits type moment a
Ron DeSantis appointee
War
a Ku Klux Klan they're calling it a
costume but I think it's really a
uniform you can't really get that as a
costume and has now resigned this is an
interesting story that is not like a
major shock to many of us Huffington
Post reports Ron DeSantis appointee
resigns after alleged KKK photo surfaces
the picture reportedly shows Jeffrey
Moore at a Halloween party wearing a Ku
Klux Klan hood and robe a Florida
Republican has left his job after a
photo of him allegedly in a KKK costume
made the rounds online this is Gadsden
County Commissioner Jeffrey Moore he's a
republican he was hand picked by Ron
DeSantis in July he has resigned from
the Board of Commissioners uh per the
Tallahassee Democrat the photo I love
these words reportedly shows more at a
Halloween party wearing a KKK hood and
robe and then you see the image here and
it has not been disputed that this is
more and he did resign after all
seemingly conceding that indeed it is
him in the picture Moore is the one
white person on the board with four
black Commissioners oh boy lives in a
county where 55 percent of the residents
are black according to U.S census data
you know one of the things I was
wondering is is there such a thing as a
KKK costume like what I mean by that is
when I Googled KKK costume you know how
on Amazon and from I don't know Target
and Walmart
you can get like a honeybee costume you
can get a uh you know Peter Pan costume
I didn't find anybody selling KKK
costumes what I found were listings on
eBay for actual bona fide KKK uniforms
and the idea of a costume seems to make
it more benign than it really is we just
have to come to terms with reality
these are the types of people
in this political movement these are the
types of people that are circulating in
Florida Republican politics and at what
point do we say these aren't that rare
of exceptions yes it's not predominant
it would be silly and it would be
inaccurate to say the majority of the
Republican party is KKK members or would
be KKK members or people fantasizing
about being in the KKK though of course
not of course not but it's also not that
rare my surprise is that the guy ended
up resigning because very often you know
the move in the Trump era is you just
double down you never admit anything you
double down you say they're trying to
cancel me it's cancel culture and all
with you know what happened to jokes
what happened to speech this is my
speech or whatever else and you don't
apologize and you just stick with it and
oftentimes it works Trump did it and it
got him elected president many times we
said in 2015 2016 this has to be the
straw that breaks the camel's back this
has to be the end of trump and then it's
not so the surprise to me is that this
ended up with a resignation
um
that's what it is if you're wondering
what this looks like and whether this is
only purportedly a KKK uniform we will
have the picture on our Instagram which
you can find at davidpackman show quick
break and we will be right back
one of our sponsors is Helix sleep I
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
for years and I always recommend it to
friends you'd simply take this Helix
sleep quiz it asks you about your body
type your sleep position whether you
have back pain and then Helix will match
you up with the mattress that is
personalized to your needs and they ship
it to you for free another reason I went
with Helix is that unlike a lot of
mattress companies out there every
single Helix mattress is made in the USA
by a skilled production team which means
when you buy a helix mattress you're
supporting great jobs I'm not the only
one who loves Helix Helix was recently
awarded number one mattress by both GQ
and Wired Magazine every Helix mattress
comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty you
can try it a hundred nights and send it
back for a full refund if you need to
support the David Pacman show by getting
your next mattress from Helix sleep and
and you'll get up to 350 off any
mattress plus two free pillows when you
go to Helix sleep.com slash Pacman the
link is down below